couple years back I was reading an
article about the search for a human
odor print this is the idea that every
human being has a different and unique
smell signature and that you might be
able to chemically detect it you know
dogs can already do this people have
unique smells but these researchers were
trying to figure out if there was a way
to systematize that here's a spoiler
most of us don't smell very good they
don't really know why it could be
something on the surface of our cells
called the major histocompatibility
complex that has to do with how our
immune system works might also be the
different bacteria that live in
different parts of our body we all have
a unique bacterial ecosystem that goes
around with us but then I saw another
article another researcher looking for a
way to find the signatures of conflict
minerals in various materials so there
are certain conflict minerals you first
stuff like Colton right that that aren't
allowed in the country it's illegal so
this researcher was using a technique
called laser-induced breakdown
spectroscopy you basically shoot a laser
at the stuff and what kind of out gases
what plumes off you can do a chemical
read on it and see what it contains so
you're looking for minerals like
wolframite or Columba tantalum now I
can't do that one anyway there's a lot
of minerals that I had trouble
pronouncing that aren't allowed in the
country but that got me thinking maybe
we should be able to see the signatures
for everything I mean everything's going
to have a unique chemical signature
right so I was looking at some of the
reports about Google Glasses google
glass that the head-up displays that
they're trying to start selling where I
don't know I guess you're walking down
the street and you can tell whatever the
local starbucks is having a sale or
something but I was thinking that what I
really want is in addition to the
head-up display i want a mask to flip
down to i want to google nose right i
want to be able to look at something and
tell what the ingredients are to know
what the molecular structures are that
are giving something its smell or its
taste or its shape by suppose to walk
into a farmers market know what the
molecules are that make that orange Ryan
smell like orange rind or what's inside
those dried blueberries I don't know
because then you can imagine a world
work you can see that stuff you can
start to UM come up with combinations
you live in a world of Legos you can
figure out what might taste or smell
good or
might look neat when put together you
would have so much more information
about the world when you walked around
and saw that you would know how to make
things out of it later or at minimum
you'd be able to point this thing in a
person walking down the street figure
they have a unique chemical odor print
and know whether you wanted a friend
them on Facebook